stocks and shares
where do you start i don't know about
stocks and shares i don't know what to
put my money in yeah i don't know what
trading is
where do i start okay uh that leads us
into a long conversation basis so
practical advice
don't worry about it put money into if
you're in the uk into stocks and shares
isa which is a savings account or in
america your roth ira 401k and if you
can invest money invest it into a stock
market index fund uh basically what that
means is that you are instead of buying
one company like apple or microsoft or
tesla or google you're buying a stake in
the top 500 companies in the in america
which would just so happen like if you
put 100 quid in something called the s p
500 um
three pounds would go to apple and you'd
own three pounds of apple two pounds
you'd own two pounds of alphabet a and b
so google you'd own two pounds of
microsoft two pounds of amazon and so on
and that means you can invest in the
stock market without worrying about
trying to cherry pick individual stocks
which doesn't work for anyone unless
you're like a very very very
professional hedge fund manager and even
then for those guys picking stocks
doesn't really work so that would be my
advice to people um but i think it does
help to have a first principal's
understanding of what the stock market
is and how that kind of stuff works i
saw a video of warren buffett's and
charlie munger giving an end-of-year
address a couple of years ago and they
were talking about i think warren had
made a bet
with a bunch of hedge fund managers to
see if they could beat the s p 500 have
you seen this video yep
so sick
so well can you explain
what happened and why that seems to be
the case
yeah so the the thing with
with funds
basically if you're a rich person you
wanna you wanna
you want your money to grow you don't
want if your money sits in a bank
account onto your mattress it deflates
over time because of inflation uh
because the government prints more money
which gets us into conversation about
crypto and stuff which will we won't go
down because i'm not very familiar with
that space trying to understand it
myself but basically money sitting on
its own reduces its value over time and
therefore if you have money you want it
to ideally increase its value over time
and one way you can do that you can do
it in real estate or you can do it by
buying and investing in stocks and
shares so you own a percentage of a
company
if you do what what i recommend and what
warren buffett and charlie munger
recommends i recommend you just invest
in an index fund which tracks the whole
stock market and you don't have to worry
about it but some people invest in
actively managed funds so that's
basically i would give you some money
i'd say chris here is a million pounds i
want you to grow my million pounds
you would say oh [ __ ] he's giving me a
million pounds i need to grow it but i
need to do something other than just
invest in the fund in the index fund
right because i need to i need to try
and be beat the market that's what
beating the market means and so you
think you know what i think tesla's
going to do well i think netflix is
going to well i think i think pets.com
is going to do well and i think i don't
know febreze is going to do well i'm
going to put a quarter of a million of
all his money into those things and i'm
really going to hope that it
outperforms what what it would have done
had i put it into just the top 500
companies in the u.s without thinking
about it
and it apparently according to warren
buffett i haven't read the research on
this firsthand myself but what warren
buffett says and what a lot of advice on
this industry is that
the funds that do well in one year like
let's say chris's fund returns 20
so my million goes to 1.2 million
whereas the s p 500 the index market
only returned 10
so if i was average joe investing in the
index fund i'd make 10 but if i gave my
money to you chris i'd make 20
uh but there's no guarantee that the
next year your fund is also making 20
and there's also no guarantee that in
year 3 your fund is still doing well and
it turns out that there are very few
funds if any that can actually just beat
the market overall which is what this
bet was that warren buffett did with all
these hedge fund managers and he ended
up winning it um and giving the money to
literally doing something that anybody
could do pressing go all in on the s p
500 which is in itself kind of a hedged
type of investment because it's across
so many different companies and you're
talking about professional hedge fund
managers that were spending time and
charging commissions and doing research
and looking at is this overpriced what's
the r number on the the fibonacci
sequence over over trend all this stuff
exactly just put it in the s p 500 and
the s p b all of them that's the one
yeah i think i think there are some
funds in the world like especially the
ones that invest in like early stage
startups and things where you probably
do beat the market but normal people
don't have access to those you have to
be like ridiculously rich to be able to
invest in those sorts of funds that do
that kind of thing it's my understanding
therefore most people should just invest
in the s p 500 or a broad stock market
index fund in the uk and in the us how
would you do that
um in the uk
basically whichever country you're in
you need to get a
um
essentially a stock broker so
back in the day a stock broker was some
dude on wall street that you would ring
up and say hey
tom i want to put 20 on apple and he'd
be like all right i'm placing that order
these days stock brokers are online so
you have these online stock trading
platforms and it varies between
different countries in the uk and the us
and a bunch of countries in europe
vanguard is the most trusted it was the
original kind of index fund place so you
just open an account with vanguard and
you put some money into it like let's
say you start with 10 100 a thousand
dollars whatever and then you can
allocate that money to one of these
funds and the one that i'm fully
invested in is the s p 500 which is just
the 500 biggest companies in the us i
don't think too hard beyond it about it
beyond that
um so that's what i'd suggest is google
best online stock broker
harvard's landsdowne is quite popular in
the uk that's quite easy to set up
and you can tie that in the allowance in
the uk is 20 000 pounds per year that
you can put in tax-free
and the
returns are also
not taxed on that so over time that 20
will be 21 22 23. um
so yes you can also set up a standing
order direct debit which i think is a
nice way to portion off a little bit of
money every single month i know that x
100 pounds goes into
that and it's also that also permits you
to do what's called dollar cost
averaging which is to peace into the
market over time so the market's going
to do these little wiggles wiggly
wiggles up and down hopefully trending
upward which means that you're
continuing to earn money but by piecing
in consistently over multiple months you
don't end up ever catching too many big
or too many low points within the market
and you get out of it on the other side
all right exactly so like i have a
monthly standing order for 500 pounds
into the s p 500 and uh 2 000 pounds
into bitcoin and ethereum
have you seen coinbase has a smart
investing thing oh i don't have it what
is that so
coinbase is a trading account that you
can use it's also a wallet for crypto
and they have a
dollar cost averaging service
that uses the movement of the price to
allocate how many how much of your funds
should go in oh so let's say that you
want to put i want to put a thousand
pounds into uh bitcoin and ethereum
every month
it will rate down or up
how much it puts in of that thousand
pounds based on the movement of the coin
during that month so if bitcoin is more
than 10 down it'll put 1400 in but if
bitcoin is more than 10 up it'll only
put 600 in so it actually sort of smart
invests based on what the recent
movement of the market has been oh
that's very sophisticated i should try
that out i'll just use the recurring buy
feature on coinbase pretty cool yeah
it's kind of like a rebalancing thing
but it happens automatically within the
app oh it's like see that and it's
pretty simple when you think about it
it's like has the price gone up a lot
okay i'm not going to put quite so much
in has the price gone down a lot okay
i'm going to put a little bit more in
less what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to subscribe
peace
you